ja meine damen und herren sie hier sind
wir wieder live die namentliche
abstimmung ist zu ende das ergebnis
kommt später hier geht es zum nächsten
programmpunkt cannabis modellprojekte
für die fdp spricht jetzt wieland
schinnenburg in seiner schoenenburg
personen in seiner ersten rede
er hat den schönen zivilberuf zahnarzt
meine damen und herren die auf
repression basierende keiner weiß
politik in diesem lande ist gescheitert
sie ist aus mehreren gründen gescheitert
ist einmal gescheitert weil nach
jahrzehnten der strafverfolger noch
mehrere millionen menschen cannabis
konsumieren
sie ist ebenfalls gescheitert weil diese
menschen auch noch zusätzlich gefährdet
werden weil cannabis auf dem
schwarzmarkt besorgen müssen und dort
oft cannabis mit verunreinigungen
bekommen was dort zu gesundheit
zusätzlich gefährdet und sie ist
drittens gescheitert bei auf diese weise
justiz und polizei unnötig mit arbeit
belastet werden ressourcen die man
anderweitig besser verwenden könnte
meine damen und herren ich habe deutlich
mehr angst vor einbruchsdiebstählen als
davor dass mein nachbar kifft deshalb
weil damals haben und ist auch so ich
habe drei töchter und meine meiner
größten sorgen war immer was passiert
wenn einer von diesen töchtern
drogensüchtig wird ich habe mich gefragt
was tut dann der start für mich dafür
meine tochter ja da war die wahl
entweder gefängnis oder schwarzmarkt
kurstag das für unbefriedigend deshalb
haben die freien demokraten schon vor
einigen jahren beschlossen wir wollen
eine andere drogen politik wir wollen
eine kontrollierte abgabe von cannabis
achtung kontrollierte abgabe nicht etwa
freigabe wir wollen nicht dass cannabis
irgendwo im supermarkt im regal liegt
nah wir wollen dass keiner besten
apotheken und anderen spezialitäten
geschäften kontrolliert an erwachsenen
in der zauberer menge abgegeben werden
was spricht dafür das so zu machen
der erste grund ist dass man auch die
weise eben verhindert dass menschen
unreines cannabis bekommt man kann es
kontrollieren der zweite grund ist weil
man dann an die besseren zugang zu den
drogenabhängige hat in vielen stellen
ihnen therapien anbieten kann
und drittens der staat nimmt viel geld
ein öffentlich und das geld kann man
dann für therapie und prävention
ausgeben
meine damen und herren dass das konzept
der freien demokraten dass wir seit drei
jahren fordern nun ein bisschen
natürlich aus in diesem hause an die
fraktionen sind die eben ein bisschen
skeptisch gegenüberstehen da machen wir
heute den ersten schritt wir fordern
zunächst mal nur ein modellprojekt liebe
kollegen von den fraktionen die das eher
konservativ so sehen ja sie können nicht
ernsthaft dagegen sein dass wir klüger
werden lassen wir sie auch ein
modellprojekt erst mal zustimmen oder
nach westen geht also unser bitte ist
stimmt sie doch ein modell vision zu
auch wenn sie vielleicht insgesamt haben
wir sind skeptisch sind und meine damen
und herren ich bringe es mal auf den
vollen punkt wir brauchen eine andere
drogen politik die den menschen in den
mittelpunkt interessen der menschen im
mittelpunkt stellt und nicht überholte
dogmen
das ist die idee der freien demokraten
ich könnte so anders ausdrücken wir
brauchen eine neue generation von drogen
politik und dafür wollen wir
unterstützen vielen dank für ihre
aufmerksamkeit
das sagt der zahnarzt dr wieland
schinnenburg von der fdp also eine
kontrollierte abgabe vor den liberalen
beziehungsweise modellprojekte für den
freien cannabisanbau der nächste redner
ist selber mediziner auch stefan
pischinger von der union aber
humangenetik der humanmedizin akademie
zum thema mariana gibt es passenderweise
viele rauschhafte fantasien
ich möchte heute zu den
wissenschaftlichen fakten sprechen und
wenn er darauf eingehen dass die
behauptungen von fdp linken und bündnis
90/die grünen teilweise nicht der
realität entsprechen
es wird behauptet dass durch die abkehr
von repressionen
die zwei staatsanwaltschaft und justiz
entlastet werden würden
fakt ist aber mit dass mit dieser
argumentation alle drogen weitergehen
freigestellt werden müssten
behauptet wird auch oft eine
kontrollierte abgabe von cannabis als
genussmittel könnte ein beitrag zum
gesundheitsschutz leisten weil dadurch
die qualität von cannabisprodukten
kontrollierbar wäre
fakt ist aber dass dann aus gesundheits
gesucht punkten alle drogen kontrolliert
abgegeben werden müssten
auch wird behauptet dass durch eine
mögliche besteuerung kann von
cannabisprodukten erhebliche einnahmen
erzielt werden würden
die sorte der suchtprävention auf
klärung zugeführt werden könnten
fakt ist aber dass erhebliche
steuereinnahmen aus dem vertrieb von
cannabis produkte nur dann zu erzielen
sind wenn möglichst viel cannabis auch
vertrieben wird das für nicht protest
tabakwerbung verbieten wollen aber
cannabis konsum zu strecken nutzen
darüber hinaus wird ja gerne behauptet
dass die kontrollierte abgabe von
cannabis völlig risikolos sei fakt ist
aber dass die schlicht falsch ist der
cannabiskonsum mit erheblichen gefahren
verbunden ist wie die jüngst
veröffentlichte gabrisch du dir der lmu
münchen belegt kann cannabis konsum zu
psychischen störungen wie angststörungen
depressionen sozialität bipolaren
störungen und so wie psychosen führen
vielfach wird auch behauptet dass
cannabiskonsum die arbeitsfähigkeit der
menschen nicht beeinträchtigt fakt ist
aber dass cannabiskonsum zu vielseitigen
kognitiven beeinträchtigungen führt in
einer prospektiven beobachtungsstudie
aus dem jahr 2016 in jamaal intention
mädchen konnte sich jeder zweite
teilnehmer in einem test ein wort
weniger aus einer liste von 15 wort
merken wenn er seit fünf jahren
regelmäßig marihuana geraucht hatte
zudem
würden sie eine zwischenfrage zueinander
jetzt bin ich gerade im fluss zudem
belegt die us-amerikanische cardia
studie dass eine hohe cannabiskonsum
langfristig spuren im verbalen
gedächtnis hinterlässt außerdem
schnitten bei der cardia studie kiffer 1
tests zur verarbeitungsgeschwindigkeit
exekutive funktionen und zum verbalen
gedächtnis umso schlechter je mehr
cannabis sie gebraucht hatten
besonders erschreckend ist bei dieser
studie dass die cannabis konsumenten bei
den tests auch dann noch schlechter
abschnitten wenn sie mittlerweile auf
cannabis verzichteten fast alle seriösen
studien machen es mehr als deutlich
intensiver cannabis konsum macht einfach
dumm
der kollege muss seine zwischenprodukten
auch wird behauptet dass cannabis nicht
gesundheitsgefährdend sein
fakt ist dass cannabis das risiko
respiratorische und thoma erhöhte
bewirkt cannabiskonsum erwartete
blutgefäße bluthochdruck beschleunigten
puls dies kann ebenfalls der caprice
studie entnommen werden
behauptet wird zudem dass cannabiskonsum
keine negativen gesellschaftlichen
folgen mit sich bringt fakt ist aber
darf die sozialen folgen von cannabis
konsum nicht zu vernachlässigen sind wie
ebenfalls die capri studie belegt früher
beginnen und häufiger cannabis konsum in
der jugend sind mit geringen
bildungschancen assoziiert auch wird
behauptet dass cannabis nicht zu
abhängigkeit führen würde oder diese
zumindest zu vernachlässigen wären
fakt ist aber dass die bereits viel
zitierte cabrio studie aufhört dass in
europa die zahl der personen die
erstmals eine sucht behandlung wegen
cannabis assoziierten problem beginn von
43.000 im jahr 2006 auf 76.000 im jahr
2015 gestiegen sind
diese entwicklung zeigt sich auch in
deutschland epidemiologische studien
schätzen sogar dass circa 9 prozent
aller personen die jemals cannabis
konsumiert haben
eine cannabis bezogene störung
entwickeln
die vorgelegten anträge sind für mich
reiner populismus
mir geht es nicht darum mich falsch
anzubiedern sondern um die gesundheit
der menschen deshalb will ich eine welt
mit weniger als mit mehr drogen vielen
dank stefan pischinger der neue
abgeordnete reihen der cdu/csu selber
arzt hat hier noch mal die haltung der
unions fraktion klar gemacht und die
nächste rednerin sabine dittmer auch sie
ist ärztin seit 2013 ihr mitglied im
hohen hause stellvertretende
gesundheitspolitische sprecherin der spd
und die spd hat ja gemeinsam mit der
union in diesem kapitel in dem kapitel
drogen in dem koalitionsvertrag
festgelegt zur gesundheitlichen gründen
ja aber keine freigabe
[Musik]
das web gebrauch von cannabis natürlich
gesundheitliche risiken mit sich birgt
auch ein suchtpotenzial in sich trägt
genauso wie alkohol und nikotin gegen
aus und deshalb soll es oder meine ich
ist es umso besorgniserregender
besorgniserregende die feststellung der
deutschen hauptstelle für suchtfragen
dass der illegalen beschaffung
smartphone breiten gesellschaftsgruppen
benutzt wird und er in seiner jetzigen
form auch kindern und jugendlichen
uneingeschränkt zur verfügung steht und
deshalb sollte es uns doch herr kollege
bill singen mächtig zu denken wenn ein
bedeutender teil von sachbeschädigungen
aus der praxis aus der forschung also
verbände und organisationen menschen die
tagein tagaus mit betroffenen zu tun
haben aber auch namhafte strafrechtler
und zu guter letzt der bund der
deutschen kriminalbeamten zu der
feststellung kommen
uns wird derzeitig praktizierte
verbotspolitik gescheitert ist meine
damen und herren in meiner partei wird
seit langem kontrovers sind
leidenschaftlich über den richtigen
umgang mit der drogenproblematik
diskutiert und ich will gar nicht
verhehlen dass es auch nach wie vor noch
stimmen gibt es werden gott sei dank
immer weniger die eine restriktive
drogenpolitik das wort geredet und ich
bin dankbar dass die progressiven
stimmen in meiner partei einfordern
einfordern sich an den
gesellschaftlichen realitäten zu
orientieren und neue wege in der
drogenpolitik zu gehen
in der arbeitsgruppe gesundheit haben
wir uns gemeinsam mit den fachpolitikern
aus ag recht und ag inne neben intensiv
mit der thematik beschäftigt und auch
ein entsprechendes positionspapier
verfasst
gemeinsam haben wir uns dafür
ausgesprochen ist den kommunen zu
ermöglichen modellprojekte zu
regulierten abgabe von cannabis an
erwachsenen anzustoßen und die
ergebnisse zu evaluieren
wenn wir sind davon überzeugt dass man
damit nicht nur den schmerz schwarzmarkt
zurückdrängen kann sondern ein neues
kapitel der drogen und suchtprävention
aufschlagen kann und vor allem auch
konsumenten wirkungsvoll
entkriminalisieren gesundheitsrisiken
würden reduziert da man eine bei einer
regulierten abgabe im gesundheitlichen
verbraucherschutz einen ganz anderen
stellenwert geben kann aber vor allem
finden wir einen sehr viel besseren
zugang zur prävention und zur effektiven
jugendschutz wir können frühzeitig
beraten frühzeitig hilfestellung
anbieten und schaden minimieren denn
dass die strafandrohung liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen als weg der
prävention doch ganz offensichtlich
gescheitert ist zeigen die zahlen
und ich frage sie auf welchen sinn hat
es wenn sich polizei und justiz mit
endkonsumenten beschäftigen müssen die
geringe mengen cannabis bei sich haben
aber eine
endlich ein aktenberg produzieren
welches öffentliche interesse sollen wir
denn daran haben die konsumenten zu
stigmatisieren und ihnen mit akten
einträgen unter umständen persönliche
zukunft zu verfassen
meine damen und herren ich wünsche mir
dass wir die debatte ohne ideologische
scheuklappen führen dass wir uns die
drogenpolitik an fakten leiten
und es ist kein geheimnis dass es ein
langer weg in der zurückliegenden
legislaturperiode war erleichterungen in
der substitutionstherapie zu vereinbaren
oder auch den zugang zu cannabis als
medizin neu zu regeln und sie liebe
kolleginnen von der fdp und von den
grünen wissen aus ihren
sondierungsgesprächen sicherlich auch
dass es bei der union aber starke
verharren müssen sondern zwischen
vorgezogen nein jetzt nicht und trotzdem
bin ich zuversichtlich dass wir eine
fachlich fundierte debatte im
gesundheitsausschuss führen werden
ich persönlich hoffe mir dass wir den
gesellschaftlichen prozessen und
veränderungen stück für stück rechnung
tragen und wir es schaffen neue wege im
umgang mit cannabis zu finden und vor
allem dabei die gesundheitliche
prävention stärken bevor es war sabine
dittmar
jetzt kommt das ergebnis des antrages
der ard das abstimmungsergebnis
namentlichen abstimmung über den antrag
der afg verhalten der bundesregierung im
fall des aufdrucks 19 846 abgegeben 630
stimmen mit ja haben gestimmt 77 mit
nein haben gestimmt 552 1 enthaltung
damit ist
abgelehnt und ich ja die 77 stimmen kam
von der afg schätzungsweise 92 hat die
fraktion war nicht jeder hier anwesend
im raum aber professor axel gercke ist
da ja auch er ist natürlich mediziner in
dieser debatte hier um cannabis hat er
jetzt das wort der präsident verehrte
kolleginnen und kollegen
wir stehen heute vor einer sehr
sensiblen entscheidung die legalisierung
von cannabis als bisher verbotene droge
wird allein schon dadurch erschwert dass
wissenschaftlich belastbare fakten
bestenfalls zur medizinischen wirkung
nicht aber zur drogenszene bestehen
daraus daraus die nun lassen sie mich
doch ausreden daraus die
schlussfolgerung zu ziehen wir müssen
cannabis legalisieren umso verlässlicher
zu verlässlichen daten zu kommen wäre
schon der erste trugschluss
nein meine damen herren die drogenszene
bliebe bestehen und da dealer im
gegensatz zu dem von ihnen eingebrachten
gesetz keine mindestalter grenze kennen
würde sich vermutlich sogar noch
ausweiten
zumindest ergibt sich für minderjährige
jugendliche kein unterschied ob mit oder
ohne legalisierung aus medizinischer
sicht ist die sache ziemlich klar es
handelt sich bei cannabis und daraus
abgeleiteten produkten um psychoaktive
substanzen die insbesondere jugendliche
in ihrem reifeprozess erheblich
gefährden und zwar umso mehr je jünger
diese sind nur reden wir von
jugendlichen da geht es ganz besonders
darum geht es
na gut aber ich bin ja jetzt hier
ampullen der sehen lassen sie mich doch
das werden
nun treten die befürworter derzeit in
breiter front an
typische argumente sind wir haben in der
jugend auch gekifft und es hat uns nicht
geschadet wobei allein das schon eine
subjektive bewertung ist und herr
schönburg das gilt auch für ihren
nachbarn und es soll ja auch nur nach
strengen regeln verkauft werden nur über
18 jahre
nur in apotheken oder in eigenen
fachgeschäften und diese dürfen aber
laut ihrem gesetz nicht in der nähe von
schulen und jugendtreffs angesiedelt
sein
als ob das eine rolle spielen würde
allein das zeigt die ganze hilflosigkeit
ihres vorhabens gegenüber den echten
fakten einer sucht nein meine damen
herren das ist nicht ein das problem wie
weit ein jugendlicher laufen muss um an
den stoff zu kommen
vielmehr steht zu befürchten dass
cannabinoide als einstiegsdroge für
härteren gangart zu werten sind
und interessanterweise kommen diese
befürchtungen genau von denjenigen die
sich am meisten mit der drogenszene
befassen
von strafverteidigern psychiatern
drogenbeauftragten elternverbänden und
bewährungshelfer und meine sehr
verehrten damen und herren ich möchte
ausdrücklich warnen
öffnen sie nicht die büchse der pandora
wir haben in der drogenbekämpfung doch
schon so viel erreicht
es ist in unserer jugend nicht mehr cool
drogen zu nehmen der zigaretten
verbrauch ist dramatisch zurückgegangen
saufpartys aller ballermann sind
geächtet eine erst kürzlich erhobene
umfrage zeigt 85 prozent der deutschen
haben angst vor drohungen und bei der
befragung von eltern mit kindern liegen
diese zahlen noch höher
was wurde bisher erreicht laut einer
studie der bundesregierung sind wir etwa
bei 10,8 prozent der bevölkerung die
irreversibel nikotinabhängig sind 3,48
prozent sind alkoholabhängig aber nur
0,6 prozent irreversibel drogenabhängig
das zeigt ganz eindeutig
drogenprävention lohnt sich und dabei
sollten wir bleiben meine damen herren
und meine damen und herren lassen sie
sich nicht durch beweisende studien in
die irre führen
es steckt fast immer eine hocheffiziente
lobby dahinter
denn wer verdient an einer freigabe für
den staat ist es ein milliardengeschäft
an der zigaretten steuer verdient der
staat jährlich 14 milliarden euro
die damit verbundenen folgekosten
schätzen fachleute auf 17 milliarden
euro soll erst in nimmt der staat ein
das zweite zahlt der bürger wollen sie
das wiederholen herr kolleginnen lassen
seine zwischen der fdp akzent sprechen
herr kollege vielen dank dass die
zwischenfrage zu lassen sprechen sich
darin konsequent auch für dieses verbot
von alkohol und nikotin aus das ist
ganz klar eigentlich müsste auch alkohol
und nikotin entsprechend verboten werden
das ist ganz klar wir haben aber keinen
grund eine dritte drogen zu lassen
und darum geht es hier hier wie dort
sind es weitere steuern auf kosten der
gesundheit der bürger und so etwas
lehnen wir grundsätzlich ab aber auch
für die produktions und pharmafirmen den
stoff vertreiben ist das ein
milliardengeschäft
in den usa gehen die marihuana aktien
durch die decke anstiege in kurzer zeit
um über 2000 prozent sind dort die rede
aber auch bei uns ist der sogenannte
cannabis index der die börsen
aktivitäten dokumentiert alleine vom
oktober 2017 bis heute in froher
erwartung um über 213 prozent gestiegen
nein meine damen und herren diese
spekulation auf kosten unserer
jugendlichen darf es nicht geben
wir haben bereits eine sehr liberale
drohen gesetzgebung wir haben die
freigabe von cannabis für medizinische
zwecke
das ist schon umstritten genug und wenn
überhaupt nur für wenige indikationen
gesichert hörgl immerhin es ist möglich
lassen sie eine zwischenfrage zu von
frauen strack zimmermann von der
fraktion dass sie eine zwischenfrage zu
belassen
meine frage geht dahin gehen sie haben
mitbekommen dass der bund der
kriminalbeamten sehr viel kraft und
energie und vor allem personal daran
bindet
dass man konsumenten jagdhund habe
dringend darauf hingewiesen dass diese
praxis beim eigenkonsum aufhört weil die
polizei in diesem land wichtigeres und
bedeutenderes zu tun hat sind sie einer
meinung mit den kriminalbeamten daß die
polizei in diesem land wichtigeres zu
tun hat als konsumenten die ein pfeife
rauchen zu jagen
nein nein frau kollegin der meinung bin
ich nicht schließe mich der meinung des
präsidenten der bayerischen polizei an
der genau dies für völligen unsinn
gehalten hat und da denke ich mal hat er
vollkommen recht
die tatsache dass der besitz von
cannabis strafrechtlich verfolgt wird
hat bisher eindeutig gute abschreckende
wirkung gezeigt und es ist mehrfach
widerlegt der irrglaube dass durch eine
legalisierung der drogen markt
ausgetrocknet wird das gegenteil ist der
fall
die dealer weichen auf billigeres auf
billiges material aus und auf härtere
drogen aus den niederlanden in dieser
lande lassen grüßen
im namen der mehrzahl der eltern dieses
landes fordere ich sie auf bleiben sie
so cool wie unsere jugendlichen und
lassen sie den geist nicht aus der
flasche die afg jedenfalls lehnt zum
schutze unserer jugend die vollständige
legalisierung kollege bist kategorisch
ab vielen dank
axel gercke war das für die afg der
nächster redner kommt von der linken der
erst nicht mediziner hat jura studiert
und ist hier schon seit der dritten
legislaturperiode jetzt im deutschen
parlament obmann der fraktion der linken
im ausschuss für wirtschaftliche
zusammenarbeit und entwicklung und
sprecher für welternährung der fraktion
nehme was man will da sehen die
insbesondere auch csu-politiker
genüsslich bier tranken sie von der csu
zelebrieren also öffentlich dass alkohol
trinken obwohl 74.000 menschen im jahr
an
alkoholkonsum an den folgen des
alkoholkonsums sterben erzählt uns hier
aber cannabis gehöre verboten
dabei ist in deutschland kein einziger
fall belegt bei dem menschen durch
cannabis gestorben sind es ist wirklich
absurd mit welchem ideologischen
scheuklappen sie drogen politik
betreiben wir haben heute als linke
einen antrag vorgelegt mit ersten
schritten wir wollen den konsum von
cannabis in kriminalisieren und eine
kontrollierte abgabe ermöglichen
wie sagen es muss endlich schluss damit
sein dass menschen nur weil sie ein
bisschen cannabis besitzes bestraft
werden ich möchte gerne drei argumente
für unseren antrag nennen erstens
erwachsene menschen dürfen sich selbst
schaden
das ist ihre persönliche freiheit laut
dem grundgesetz deshalb darf von alkohol
trinken
man darf rauchen und amanda vom
straßenverkehr teilnehmen obwohl all das
gefährlich ist wer mal einen joint
raucht schadet niemandem dritten
allenfalls schadet er sich selbst 122
strafrechts professorinnen und
professoren haben schon vor fünf jahren
ähnlich argumentiert sie sprachen von
einer einschränkung der bürgerrechte
durch die jetzige drogenpolitik was wir
heute im umgang mit cannabis
cannabiskonsumenten erleben ist eine
entmündigung erwachsener menschen
selbstbestimmten lebens herr kollege
lassen sondern zwischen vorgezogen und
kollegen der fdp fraktion ein zweites
argument die bisherige cannabis politik
ist eine unfassbare verschwendung der
ressourcen von polizei und justiz
millionenbeträge werden versenkt um ein
paar kiffer zu verfolgen laut
kriminalstatistik von haben von den
insgesamt 300.000 erfassten
rauschgiftdelikten 183.000 ein cannabis
bezug
mein wechsel zwischen frage von den
kollegen der cdu csu fraktion
ja herr kollege bei dem thema kosten
wir wissen dass durch den cannabis
konsum schon jetzt fast eine milliarde
euro aufgewandt werden muss für die
gesundheits- und sozialsysteme ist ihnen
das bewusst dass das auch von allen zu
tragen ist und nicht nur von denen die
sozusagen das konsumieren
herr kollege herr kollege also es ist
natürlich richtig dass menschen die sich
die sozusagen sucht wichtig sind acht
oder bestimmten drogen dass das
natürlich kosten im gesundheitssystem
verursacht das ist aber auch bei alkohol
und das ist auch bei tabak sowie ihr
kollege und das problem das problem löst
sich eben nicht durch verbote in diesem
fall sollen durch gesundheitsangebote
und der schwarzmarkt der schafft
wirklich noch viel mehr probleme als
wenn man das entkriminalisieren würde
muss wirklich sagen es ist eine ganz
tolle leistung wenn man ein paar
menschen ja gras wegnimmt und parkin
kriminalisiert das nützt doch niemanden
in diesem land das hat ja selbst der
bund deutscher kriminalbeamter gesagt
der jüngst forderte endlich ein ende der
kriminalisierung herbeizuführen und es
ist richtig polizei und justiz haben
wichtigeres zu tun als ein paar cannabis
konsumenten zu verfolgen aller welt
hinein drittes argument wenn die
bisherige verbotspolitik ist
gesundheitsschädlich
denn durch die kriminalisierung gibt der
staat die kontrolle und die regulierung
des cannabis marktes komplett auf die
kriminalisierung es schafft einen großen
schwarzmarkt und dort werden dann
verunreinigte oder gar tödlicher
substanzen in umlauf gebracht und in den
niederlanden haben wir ja wohl cannabis
jahr geduldet ist haben wir solche
probleme eben nicht deshalb ist ein
legaler zugang zu cannabis ein echter
beitrag zum gesundheitsschutz
wir haben uns hier leider ignorieren ja
insbesondere sie von der union und das
erinnert in seiner fachlichen fall
scheint schon fast an die klima leugnung
von donald trump alle fachlichen
argumente die für eine
entkriminalisierung des cannabis
sprechen und einer spitze ist da dabei
die drogenbeauftragte marlene mortler
die er immer wieder neue peinliche
äußerungen von sich gibt es wer wirklich
an der zeit die endlich zu entlassen
meine damen und herren im wahlkampf hat
ja martin schulz gesagt dass cannabis
thema sei eine gewissensfrage und
deshalb sage ich liebe kolleginnen
kollegen der spd wollen sie sich nicht
irgendwelchen ideologischen
koalitionsvereinbarung die haben noch
gar nicht gelten doch sind sie ja ganz
frei in ihrer entscheidung und ihr
fraktionschef hier im land berlin hat ja
ihr habt ja richtigerweise gestern sogar
die legalisierung von cannabis gefordert
lassen sie uns doch ihren bundestag erst
mal starten mit dem kleinen schritt
wieder eine entkriminalisierung um mit
dem schaffen von legalen
zugangsmöglichkeiten dass wir doch mal
anfangen dankeschön
da die linke will den besitz von
eigenbedarf erlauben und das verbot des
besitzes von kleinstmengen kippen die
grünen wollen einen streng
kontrollierten legalen markt für
cannabis und jetzt redet für die grünen
nämlich dr kirsten kaputt konter sie ist
fachärztin für psychiatrie und
psychotherapie und auf dem schwarzmarkt
gibt es weder gesundheits noch
jugendschutz libanon die vernunft und
rhede evidenz herr kollege bösinger
gebietet endlich die kontrollierte
freigabe von cannabis
dazu legen wir grünen heute ein
umfassendes gesetz vor unser gesetz
regelt vom anbau bis zur zum verkauf
alles und zwar immer mit dem gesundheits
und jugendschutz fest im blick
und ich finde es gut
herr dr schönburg dass die fdp hier eine
initiative eingereicht in den
sondierungsgesprächen haben sie das
thema ja noch vollkommen uns überlassen
und in der luft und in der als sie noch
im bundes
schavan hat ihre kollegin initiativen
zur entkriminalisierung als rausch
sozialismus bezeichnet ich finde es gut
ich finde es ausdrücklich gut dass sie
das jetzt anders sehen und wir sind
offen für den schulterschluss mit allen
hier im haus die eine vernünftige
progressive drogenpolitik wollen und das
stimmt es nicht
das stimmt es nicht sehr zuverlässig
kollege dittmer dass sie sich heute so
vernünftig progressiv und komplett
richtig hier eingelassen haben wenn wir
sie auch an unserer seite haben dann
kann das wirklich noch was werden froh
kollegen erlauben seine zwischen volk
sondern hilfe von der fdp fraktion die
fdp und die linken beides anträge die
richtige schritte vorschlagen aber
kleine schritte meiner meinung nach
unserer meinung nach sind wir viel
weiter
die linken fordern ja auch ein gesetz
was die kontrollierte freigabe regelt
und genau dieses komplette gesetz legen
wir hier heute vor
tun wir doch endlich butter bei die
fische und warum war hier zwischen und
gesundheitsschäden die rede
warum setzte ich mich als fachärztin und
sucht medizinerin immerhin mit über
zwanzigjähriger praktische erfahrung so
wäre die kontrollierte freigabe ein weil
der witz ist doch was sie hier
beschreiben das an gesundheitsschäden
das passiert alles unter den bedingungen
der prohibition
sie müssen endlich mal der tatsache ins
auge sehen dass jeder
möglichen gefahr und nicht jeder
cannabiskonsum ist automatisch schädlich
aber jede mögliche gefahr durch die
prohibition verschlimmert wird auf dem
schwarzmarkt kenner des zu kaufen ist
als wurden sie in eine kneipe gehen und
sagen einmal alkohol bitte und sie
wissen nicht ob sie bier oder wodka
trägen dafür streckmittel inklusive und
auf dem schwarzmarkt fragt auch niemand
nach dem ausweis der jugendschutz
existiert dort rein gar nicht und jahr
der schwarzmarkt lebt ganz überwiegend
von cannabis und wenn man dem partner
des cannabis entzieht dann trocknet das
den schwarzmarkt aus so ist die
situation
wir fordern von der bundesregierung
verenden sie endlich die
gesundheitsgefährdung durch die pro
edition die evidenz ist noch da wir
brauchen keine neuen modellprojekte
gucken wir doch auf die guten
erfahrungen aus colorado ganz aktuell
aus kalifornien hören sie auf die
strafrechtlerin und strafrechtler des
schildauer kreises auch andré schulz der
vorsitzende des deutschen
bundeskriminalamtes kürzlich gesagt
unsere polizei und justiz hat wahrlich
wichtigeres zu tun als nutzerinnen und
nutzer zu verfolgen
es ist doch absurd es ist doch absurd
dass wir derzeit etwa neunmal mehr geld
für die verfolgung der nutzerinnen
ausgeben als für die prävention übrigens
kollege paul singer auf die hälfte der
hausärztinnen und hausärzte sprachen
sich in einer ganz frischen umfrage für
die freigabe aus und in der psychiatrie
ist es lange schon dann im schwange dass
wir wissen die gesundheitsgefahren
werden schlimmer durch die prohibition
also liebe kolleginnen und kollegen es
ist an der zeit die prohibition endlich
zu beenden
ich freue mich auf die debatte im
gesundheitsausschuss vielen dank zu
einer kurzintervention erfreulich dass
worte im kollegen hilfe von
reparaturen vielen dank herr präsident
die meisten von ihnen wissen ich hatte
es schon erwähnt dass ich seit über 30
jahren polizeibeamter war und zwar im
streifendienst und bei über 80 prozent
aller feststellungen von cannabis haben
wir gleichzeitig christel matt gefunden
christel matt ist ihnen sicherlich
bekannt führt zu einem sehr sehr
schnellen und drastischen geistigen und
körperlichen abbau unter polizistin ist
es in der zwischenzeit wirklich klar
dass cannabis eine einstiegsdroge für
christel matt ist ich möchte dass sie
das dass sie das bitte beachten
vielen dank kassen hilfe war dass von
der af de mit einer kurzintervention und
ich glaube unter den bedingungen der
schwarzmarkt es unter den bedingungen
der prohibition kann cannabis kann
cannabis eine einstiegsdroge sein der
witz ist ja gerade dass wir das cannabis
aus dem schwarzmarkt herauslösen wollen
und in entsprechenden fachgeschäften
unter den bedingungen des
gesundheitsschutzes und unter den
bedingungen des jugendschutzes freigeben
wollen und dann und dann haben die
nutzerinnen und nutzer eben auch nicht
mehr das risiko dass cannabis was sie
auf dem schwarzmarkt erwerben
verunreinigt ist nicht nur durch
streckmittel sondern auch durch
zusätzliche synthetische substanzen die
nämlich extra von den dealern
beigemischt werden auf dem schwarzmarkt
um die konsumenten an andere substanzen
zu binden
also auch das was sie hier gerade
vorgetragen haben spricht für die
kontrollierte freigabe
so jetzt mussten sie lange warten auf
ihre erste geräte zuerst geräte weil ich
das wort teamkollegen alexander kraus
von der cdu/csu verfassung
herr präsident meine sehr geehrten damen
und herren wir haben jetzt viel
diskutiert was wäre wenn wir so eine
liberale drogenpolitik hätten uns hier
von der fdp haben ein modellprojekt
gefordert wir müssen uns das in der tat
gar nicht so schwer machen und können
einfach mal die anderen länder schauen
frau kollegin kaputt konto hatte den
bundesstaat colorado angesprochen gehabt
ich war vor wenigen monaten in colorado
gewesen
ein bundesstaat der vor vier jahren die
drogenpolitik liberalisiert hat und ich
bin dort mit einer erkenntnis nach hause
gefahren
punkt eins der drogen konsum zugenommen
punkt zwei jugendliche kommen leichter
an drogen an weil es halt immer und dem
erwachsenen gibt der ihnen das zeug dann
billig verkauft das waren die
erkenntnisse und meine sehr geehrten
damen und herren ich brauche deine san
francisco gewesen wenn wir einen san
francisco denken da denken wir an die
straßenbahn diese schönen bergauf und
runterfahren
wir denken an bayern wir denken an das
meer ich war geschockt ich war geschockt
von dieser stadt
wenn man durch die straßen gelaufen ist
hat es überall nach cannabis turin
gesprochen
überall lagen hunderte hunderte
obdachlose in dieser stadt herum die wie
menschlicher ja meine damen und herren
das du mir leid 3 alexander kraus aber
wir wollen ihnen gleich die tagesschau
zeigen hier geht es noch ein bisschen
weiter um die frage cannabis
modellprojekten jahr oder nein
die neue bundesregierung sollte es dazu
kommen wird kann ein beste medizinische
zwecke zu lassen aber sonst nicht so ist
der sachstand
das war es hier heute aus dem deutschen
bundestag morgen setzen wir unsere
sendung um 8 uhr 30 vor hier aus dem
plenum
und da geht es um das elterngeld plus
die partnerschafts bonus und die
elternzeit seien sie also auch dann
wieder dabei hier gleich die tagesschau
vielen dank für ihr interesse ich darf
mich verabschieden einen schönen abend
[Applaus]